Paradise Lost John Milton's most famous
and arguably best piece of work
according to most people just not the
poet himself that Accolade would go to
the sequel Paradise regained now if that
title doesn't sound familiar join the
club because like many sequels it's just
not held in the same regard as the
original much to the annoyance of Milton
to provide some context surrounding the
sequel Paradise regained was considered
inferior to Paradise Lost by fans of
Milton and readers in general at the
time it was published and that opinion
still holds firm today that's not to say
Paradise regained is a bad piece of
literature by any stretch of the
imagination however Milton is a victim
of his own success here but we can
discuss some of the reasons why later on
in the video so what about the story
itself to start Paradise regained is
around 2000 lines as opposed to Paradise
Lost ten thousand five hundred so it is
significantly shorter than the original
the four books of paradise regained
follow the events of Paradise Lost where
the Son of God arrives on Earth after
being baptized by John the Baptist he
spends 40 days and nights in the desert
where he must overcome the Temptation Of
Satan at its very core this narrative
can be seen as a battle against sin or
even one's very own faith as we've seen
in the work of Dante in order to
overcome the different kinds of sin and
Temptation one must show a variety of
heavenly virtues
book one begins on the Jordan River as a
congregation Witnesses the baptism of
Jesus by John the Baptist as this
happens the heavens open and a voice
announces to all those present that
Jesus is the son of God this is the
first time Jesus himself would have
heard this and it's the start of his
journey to becoming the ordained Messiah
witnessing this meeting is Satan who now
knows the true identity of the Son of
God the news concerns him as he is one
step closer to realizing his Destiny and
in turn the punishment for Satan and
those in Hell draws ever closer Satan
returns to his Council of demons and
discusses what he has just seen the rule
that they had over mankind will be cut
short if the Son of God is allowed to
realize his mission Satan takes on the
responsibility of being the one to
oppose the Son of God confident to that
having already corrupted Adam and Eve he
will also be able to lead the Son of God
down a path of evil watching on from
Heaven God reassures the angel Gabriel
that he is well aware of Satan's plan
and his overconfidences of no concern in
fact this plan for Satan to corrupt his
son all falls into his overall divine
plan the ultimate test for his son for
those confused regarding the state of
Satan and his followers Paradise Lost
ends with them being turned into
serpents or at least that is the
prophecy foretold by God a punishment
that will happen in the future once his
son fulfills the divine plan since then
Adam and Eve were cast from Eden and
whilst on Earth Satan and his followers
have been able to corrupt and sow the
seeds of sin amongst mankind after his
baptism Jesus returns to his mother Mary
with the news that he is the Son of God
she then explains the extraordinary
circumstances surrounding his birth now
faced with the daunting Prospect of
being the Messiah he wanders the desert
where he shall fast for 40 days and 40
nights hoping for Clarity on how to
begin his mission this is where Satan
first appears to the Son of God in the
disguise of an elderly man he can see
that the Son of God is struggling with
his fast and decides to test whether he
can resist the temptation that comes
with Hunger he tries to befriend the Son
of God suggesting that he has no need to
feel the pain of hunger as the Son of
God he could simply turn the stones
around him into bread after a while he
starts to recognize the old man and can
see through his disguise he tells Satan
that a man does not need bread or food
to live all he does need is the word of
God in book 2 the Son of God continues
to roam the desert in contemplation of
the task ahead of him Satan returns to
his counsel to discuss their next
approach making it known that deceiving
the Son of God will be a much harder
task than deceiving Adam and Eve Belial
discusses the option of trying to use
women to seduce the Son of God similar
to how Solomon was seduced Satan rejects
belial's plan stating that only a weak
mind would fall for this plan instead
they would need something grander such
as the promise of Glory amongst men back
in the desert the Son of God continues
to feel hunger but he must test his
resolve until God is ready he closes his
eyes and when he wakes A well-dressed
man stands before him the man is
accompanied by a banquet of food this is
of course once again Satan who makes the
food vanish when the Son of God declines
his offer Satan instead offers him
riches Beyond his wildest imagination he
would be able to feed and raise an army
of his followers the Son of God rejects
the offer claiming that great riches are
not needed to perform great Deeds he
then gives numerous examples from the
Bible one of these being King David who
began his life as a humble Shepherd
what's interesting here is the nature of
the Temptation being offered by Satan
and how it changes in Paradise Lost
Satan tempts Eve into disobeying God and
in turn committing an act of evil this
works because Eve does not have the same
connection to God as his son she lacks
the necessary knowledge and experience
which leads to her naivety and curiosity
overcoming her the Son of God however is
well aware of his mission and is
wholeheartedly committed to God God and
so Satan changes his approach instead of
tempting the Son of God through direct
Disobedience he instead gives him the
choice to act in a virtuous way the
Dilemma of one's Faith over the
perceived right thing to do Satan uses
the cardinal virtues to try and
accomplish this when he first approaches
the Son of God he offers him food
accepting this offer can be seen as a
selfish act the next time he approaches
the Son of God he offers him riches that
could be used to feed all of his
followers and benefit them many as
opposed to the few from an outside
perspective what Satan is now doing is
giving the Son of God a choice where
rejecting his offer may also be seen as
selfish he is giving him the chance to
display the cardinal virtues in this
case it would be charity the chance to
help those in need the caveat or dilemma
being that your faith in what could
happen would have to take a back seat do
I wait and trust that God will help
these people when the time is right or
do I take initiative and help them
myself right now what would normally be
an interesting and nuanced discussion as
to what the choice should be never
really takes place the response from the
Son of God is a Biblical reference
followed by his unwavering belief in
God's plan for him and this never really
changes this is the main issue that many
including myself have with Paradise
regained Milton does a great job
imposing these questions of morality to
his audience however his own character
seem to lack even the most basic skills
of comprehension the questions they are
posed are ignored in favor of an almost
automated response the two most complex
characters in Milton's poems are Satan
and Eve they show a will willingness to
question learn and understand the world
as it works and why Adam's character
does also experience this change once
Eve Falls victim to Satan's Temptation
because he is then faced with his own
moral dilemma where he chooses Eve over
paradise and in turn his connection to
God Paradise regained doesn't really
have any of these dilemmas or moral
choices with its characters the Son of
God is placed in situations where he
faces a tough decision and questions of
morality are raised however he doesn't
even seem to comprehend what is truly
being asked of him he simply offers a
rebuttal and a reference of some kind
the entire purpose of his time in the
wilderness is to test him but we never
really see any internal struggle nor
deviation or questioning of his belief
it doesn't seem like a very difficult
test now this very well might be by
Design from Milton but it does create a
frustrating dynamic between the Son of
God and Satan as well as making the
story very very predictable anyway
context and criticism aside Satan plans
on using the virtues of Hope and Faith
in the next two books
in book three Satan changes his approach
once again his offer shifts from riches
to power he tells the Son of God that he
is indeed very wise but after this
compliment comes a barrage of insults
despite his wisdom he has achieved so
little in his life there are men who at
the same age had achieved a greatness
Alexander the Great had conquered almost
half of the World by the age of 30.
Satan continues to goad the Son of God
questioning why he chooses to waste his
time alone in the wilderness when he
could be out in the world achieving
greatness why does he choose to hide his
gifts when instead he could be using
them for good the conclusion he comes to
is that the Son of God has spent too
much time in his home he has never been
outside to experience the world and so
he has become accustomed to lingering in
his own thoughts and ideas as opposed to
acting on
the Son of God rebukes this by saying he
does not wish to gain Glory like some
men through the means of evil and
violence Satan responds by saying there
is nothing wrong with seeking glory
after all his own father God does the
same thing so why should he not follow
his father's example the only response
he can muster is that it's wrong for man
to seek Glory but okay for God because
it has been earned Satan then takes the
Son of God to a Mountaintop where he can
see all of the kingdoms and armies in
the world he tells him to pick any of
these kingdoms and the Army will be at
his disposal he will be able to free his
people and resist to Rome again the Son
of God gives an odd response he tells
Satan that the Israelites deserve to be
enslaved for their sins and he will form
his own kingdom when the time is right
as we discussed this is Satan's attempt
to allow the Son of God to give hope to
his people however this virtue is denied
using the justification that his people
must have sinned and therefore deserve
to be enslaved as punishment book 4
continues from The Mountaintop this time
Satan shows the Son of God Rome and
offers him the kingdom he declines once
again and Satan questions why he would
not want to overthrow such an evil
leader again the Son of God tells Satan
that the suffering under the Roman
Empire is deserved and he was not sent
by God to stop the Roman Empire the
Romans will be responsible for the
collapse of their own kingdom because
they have forsaken all virtues for the
desire of Earthly Pleasures instead they
must be patient because when his kingdom
is created the Earthly monarchies will
all be overthrown it's at this point in
the poem where Satan realizes there is
nothing he can do to sway the Son of God
from his mission he offers him every
Kingdom he can see they will all bow
down to him unsurprisingly he once again
says no he then shows him the glory of
Athens the great philosophers Socrates
Aristotle and Plato all of their wisdom
could be his but the Son of God
denounces this as false wisdom
frustrated that nothing he offers seems
to tempt the Son of God he returns him
to the desert Satan leaves him in the
middle of the desert as a storm rages he
gives him terrible visions and
Nightmares but none of this is enough to
break his resolve the next morning Satan
takes him to the Pinnacle the very top
of the Temple of Jerusalem he asks him
to prove his divinity by throwing
himself off if he was truly the Messiah
then surely the Angels would catch him
this is where Satan tempts the Son of
God into showing the virtue of Faith so
far we've seen Faith from a
philosophical standpoint but this is
where Satan essentially asked the Son of
God to prove that he is really the son
of God with these Stakes being his own
life if his faith is misplaced however
the self-doubt that Satan tried to
install is unsuccessful as the Son of
God refuses quoting tempts are not the
Lord thy God it's at this point Satan
has no doubt that he really is the Son
of God Jesus himself who always believed
it to be true now has confirmation that
he is the Messiah Satan in disbelief is
the one who falls from the Pinnacle with
no choice but to return to his Council
of demons defeated the Angels appear to
sing songs of Jesus's victory over Satan
Paradise lost at began with the fall of
Satan and Paradise regained ends with
the fall of Satan
the consensus seems to be that Paradise
Lost was a complete piece of literature
that did not need a sequel the biggest
difference between the two stories is
definitely the style they are written in
Paradise Lost is full of extravagant
language similes and metaphors that
paint a grand image but one that is
still vastly open to interpretation this
is all gone in Paradise regained it is a
much more plain style where everything
is very literal and there is no room for
interpretation some argue this change in
style was influenced by the clergy who
preferred a very simple style when it
came to text relating to religion
however it is important to note that we
saw this same style or at least a
transition into this style in the last
two books of Paradise Lost the main
reason I wanted to provide the context
was to answer any questions from those
wondering why Paradise Lost is so
revered and yet Paradise regained is
essentially the Forgotten sequel
[Music]
[Music]
foreign